what's going on everybody
edge of tomorrow is hitting theaters and
in the movie Tom Cruise is living the
same day over and over again people in
movies are time traveling in cool ways
all the time and that got me thinking
how far away are we from that technology
that's why I'm bringing in a couple of
scientists to break down the physics of
movie time front so dr. Johnson you said
we're seemingly a long way off
from actual time-travel but I would
contend that we've had glimpses of it in
many major motion pictures edge of
tomorrow just a Groundhog Day rip off a
retreading let's be polite the movie
edge of tomorrow would you call it a
ripoff of groundhogs day I would indeed
obviously and let's face it Bill Murray
did it better
Bill Murray does most things better so
Murray does everything better
mm-hmm what if I wake up and it's
yesterday what's the science of that
probably everything in that loop would
just keep going back so so bill wouldn't
know that it was yesterday because he'd
be back in yesterday and so he'd be
himself yesterday but I love the idea of
being stuck in the loop and Luke just
exists just you're in the loop forever
okay how I mean I wouldn't want that to
happen to me oh sure the idea yeah
having to see Ned Ryerson all the Exile
and at the head yeah
needlenose Ned right yeah watch that
first step it's uh remember doozy okay
thank you to imagine that you'd go
through the same day over and over would
mean that every time you fell asleep you
would wake up and it would be the day
before they'd say I love can't pay the
rent but baby
the money's all been spent is it
realistic for one to go back in time by
going 88 miles per hour in a DeLorean
flowing through a flux capacitor I don't
know until you tell me more about how
that thing works I just explained how it
worked
they still haven't told me enough first
you have to make me a flux capacitor and
then let's try it out but I would say so
far that's probably not likely what you
have to do to travel in time is you have
to warp you to bend space and time
itself mm-hmm if that's all the energy
you had it's probably not enough
you need things on the scale of entire
stars and solar systems like a bolt of
lightning mmm bolt of lightning is
hitting and talking I'm gonna do it what
about okay well I love the idea but as
far as we know that's not gonna do it
have you heard of these three types of
time travel and movies fixed timeline
dynamic timeline and multiverse yep
people play with scenarios where you're
going back in time and all of those
visits and things you change or don't
change are your time line there is no
other sort of alternative well people
have other scenarios where they go back
you change something and you'd go well
logically that doesn't make sense
because you know you came from the
future to change of things so you stop
yourself from ever going back to change
the thing and so it seems inconsistent
so what they do is they say oh well what
happens you go back you change it and
then it creates a different timeline
yeah there's no logical inconsistency
anymore the sum of all those universes
is called the multiverse in those
scenarios that the trend now seems to be
to reset and go fits clear writing
mistakes by having in a franchise a time
travel one where you can go back and
reset everything that's exactly what
x-men is right but it's bad so JJ Abrams
dead or anything else you could imagine
this being a trend yeah singing Peter
Jackson might want to go back and redo
those Hobbit movies or just just make
them into one movie yeah
trim the fat Jackson how would one go
about accessing the circuits of time the
circuits of time that are attached to a
phone booth the phone booth is the
vehicle I'm just gonna go ahead and stop
you there and say no no I'm gonna take
bill and ted's the circuits of time as a
big No who'd win in a fight time copper
demolition man uh-huh thunk oh no you
know how I know that uh-huh Sylvester
Stallone fought jean-claude Van Damme
and the Expendables to uh then solicitor
Stallone won I'm sorry doctor would you
call cryogenics the lazy man's time
travel so far we haven't been able to
freeze a human body for anything longer
than a couple of days and so you'd be
pretty much much brain by the time you
no matter what you did Sylvester
Stallone was perfectly fine are you sure
you was have you ever seen the movie
quantum leap uh uh
requestion doctor it's a televisions a
TV show that's right yes okay I failed
again
I remember the TV show quantum leaping
is it happening kid does man have the
technology the power to quantum leap we
do not have that technology um but
really recently we managed to make an
atom disappear and reappear a battle and
feet later Adam who what was Adams last
name Adam you know little tiny particles
we're all made up of oh and at home
that's the one
did you see x-men Days of Future past I
did if I have a friend with mutant
phasing powers right can they send my
mind back to my former self I'm very
confused about that because I thought
Kitty Pryde just walk through walls but
a lot of people were confused at that
tail here's a guy like you're not the
only one here's what I like about ya if
all of the movies are really from the
point of view of Wolverine then there's
nothing wrong with Wolverine
time-traveling in his mind uh-huh as he
kind of does in the movie and then the
time-travel is perfectly feasible
because all we're doing is changing his
point of view so maybe it's not physics
at all maybe it was all psychology you
know I shouldn't be but I'm somewhat
surprised that you're such a nerd I'm a
scientist it goes with the territory
indeed what if like in Planet of the
Apes I travel in a spaceship at close to
the speed of light resulting in time
dilation where i HZ well time passes
more rapidly on earth that is something
we know actually is scientifically
correct that's exactly what we're
talking about that is an actual possible
thing that could happen there's this
scenario where you can actually go off
at a significant clip you come back time
will for you will have passed more
slowly from the people on earth 20 30
years for you would be maybe 200 years
for me here on earth you're learnin
scientific opinion a rough percentage on
how likely it is that will be ruled by
Apes one day
haha some would say that it already is
if we rule the earth right because we're
all about James ah a darwinian hmm I
don't have enough data to say so I can't
just like I'm gonna need to bring in a
quantum zoologist yeah that'd probably
be better well I think we've solidly
proven that I know nothing about science
are you interested in time travel
how would you travel and where would you
go leave us an answer in the comment
section below
best answer you're gonna get a screen
junkies t-shirt I want to thank you for
spending time with us I'm Hal Rudnick
hit me up on Twitter bye bye Charles
dance AKA Tywin Lannister he was in Last
Action Hero he played the bad guy you
know with the pretty lass I know sequent
for you